وضع ليس بالجديد على الصين وتايوان
فالفجوه بين الجزيره والبر الرئيسي لها
جذور تاريخيه تعود الى القرون الوسطى لكن
الازمه الحديثه تولدت بعض الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
بعد الحرب الاهليه الصينيه عام
1949 استولى الشيوعيون بزعامه موتسيتونج
على الصين ليلجا القوميين في حزبكم من
تانك بقياده تشانكاي تشيك الى تايوان لكن
الحرب بدات عام
1954 عندما سيطرت قوات الكومنتانغ على
مجموعه جزر قريبه من بر الصين كان لابد
للصين ان تخاف وتقصف الجزر لكنها فشلت في
الاستيلاء عليها وضمت عوضا عنها
جزريجياك تشان شماليه تايوان
هدوء نسبي سيطر على الطرفين حتى عام
ليتجدد القصف الصيني على الجزر التي ضمتها
تايوان ما ادى للتدخل الامريكي الذي كاد
ان يؤدي الى حرب النوويه لولا ان الصين
اعلنت وقف اطلاق النار
سنوات مضت لكن الزياره الرئيس التايواني
الى الولايات المتحده عام 95 كانت كافيه
لاشعال الفتيل مره اخرى كونه كان سعيا
لاستقلال تايوان لتقوم الصين باطلاق
صواريخ في مياه الجزيره واستمرت التجارب
الصاروخيه لسنوات
[موسيقى]
كانت زياره نوت كينج ريتش رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي عام
1997 هي الاولى في التاريخ لكن نانسي
بيلوسي مشت على خطاه في اغسطس الماضي
زياره دبلوماسيه اثارت جنون الصين لتعلن
عن تدريبات عسكريه لحمايه مبدا الصين
الواحده في محيط جزيره تايوان
رد للزياره قامت به رئيسه تايوان لرئيس
مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن في 2023
لتتزامن تدريبات عسكريه صينيه مع طول فتره
زيارتها محاكيه تطويقه تايوان او ربما
غزوها
بينما تستمر الولايات المتحده في دعمها
للجزيره الصغيره عسكريا ومعنويا اصبح
التايوان نقطه خلاف سياسيه اساسيه بين
واشنطن وبكين والتي تصر على مبدا الصين
الواحده عمر العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات